china and russia continue to threaten
america but the u.s military seems to be
more worried about its own
soldiers the new report shows that the
pentagon has been working with
an extremism analyst company to dig
through the web history of troops
to find a so-called white supremacist
amongst us and one phrase they are
looking for is the truth behind black
lives matter saying quote
the search suggests the blm movement has
nefarious motives
and is a disinformation narrative
perpetuated by white supremacist groups
to weaponize anti-bl blm sentiment so
since when did doing research on a
controversial organization
make you a racist former air force
commander matthew lohmeyer lost his post
after questioning the rise of
diversity issues in the military and
joins us now does this surprise you
that this is now fact within the
military
brian thanks for having me first off
i'll say that these are my own views and
not those of the dod
uh you know very little surprises me
anymore
as i continue to consider just how
focused
it seems that the defense department is
on rooting out
white extremism and white supremacy in
the services right now
i'm not sure exactly how it is that
you're able to tell from
search terms that much about the
individuals that are serving in uniform
in fact
one of the thoughts i had just this
morning is that if you'd like to
call for a down day across all of your
military services and ask
for us to discuss uh white supremacy for
example you're going to have
many many internet hits searching for
that very topic trying to understand the
issue before you show up and have the
conversation
i did that very thing another thing that
i did in writing my book irresistible
revolution
was study quite a bit about the black
lives matter political project and it's
nothing short of a political project
in 2015 the blm movement founders
patrice khan cullers alicia garza were
interviewed by the san francisco weekly
and they stated they're uh what i'll
call an exceptionally
politicized uh project uh they're
interested in the uh dismantling of the
nuclear family because
they oppose traditional judeo-christian
values they're interested
in and revolutionizing us as a country
socially and politically
so that's a reason to look it up i mean
i don't care where you stand it's a
reason to look it up there's legitimate
questions there why are they using a uk
company
that is affiliated with barack obama
well i can't answer that brian i'm not
sure one i'm not a part of the
decision-making process and i can't even
pretend to confirm whether or not
or the degree to which that kind of
searching is going on but
the defense department has essentially
said as much in the past couple of
months that they're going to be looking
into social media posts
here's a question i've got instead of
trying to
identify who the extremists are based on
the search terms that they happen to be
looking up
on the internet how about we actually
spend our time and resources actually
focusing on
those few service members who have been
exceptionally politically partisan
left-leaning politically partisan in the
past year uh both publicly supporting
black lives matter slogans such as
burning cities down and
and overthrowing the the country uh why
don't we go after
people who are saying in their social
media posts f the police and all cops
are bastards i mean those are
exceptionally
politicized statements that we seem to
not be interested in discovering
uh i'm not sure why that is but i've
written at least 40 pages in a book
calling out specific examples and i've
not been asked once to
to point out uh who any of those
individuals are there's a particular
type of extremism we seem to be focused
on
yeah uh matt the problems on our
military uh the problems elsewhere i'm
pretty confident
our military picks the best men and
women i trust their commanding officers
to weed that out
matt thanks so much i appreciate it i
look forward to reading your book hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now